[Music]
respect the man who has a job and is
only endangered because he has to come
to work and yes to realize that he's
gonna go home or not I'm not I'm not
taking time that's what makes you better
because you have a cottage you gotta
care about
you know what basic office they're all
part of the same system vote him out
right but this isn't a voting issue this
is an issue of our voting
and bobbing comes in tomorrow it's going
to be the same issue because it's based
on a system of it's just like racism
[Applause]
[Music]
supremacy white nationalism so when I
heard so what I heard you guys telling
the cops to walk with us I was looking
at all of y'all different because
they're doing the same thing they can
watch with us today but tomorrow they're
still gonna get out without you crabs
lanes you guys registered amendment was
never abolished look at the mass
incarceration system it's multiple black
and brown bodies it was built against
people like me some black women tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you doing at home are you
telling your racist parents that their
dance of life behaviors are wrong
[Applause]
we're the ones that are going to bring
the change so unless you're actually out
here to change and if you're treating
average you do not belong here because
white supremacy helps people like Donald
Trump it helps people like Joe Biden
help even have the [ __ ] Obama crowd
donate the bails can people get people
out of prisons but also if you're white
start start riots and you're just gonna
scrape me what what do you what you're
doing but end of the day it's people
like me people with this skin color who
can't blame for it are they standing up
they get the firm they brockton they
brought the box
we're gonna burn so again if it gets
violent it started with them so I don't
want you telling me I walk with them I'm
not walking with the cop that kill me
tomorrow and if you don't want to do
that go ahead but just like you're not
part of the constant part of the issue
you're part of the problem I have been
shot up I have been aimed at I have been
gassed
I watched a young woman be dragged by
her [ __ ] hair for resisting arrest
because she was exercising her right to
protest peacefully if you're not back
you see black people walking down the
street don't grab your purse tighter
don't process the equation don't stare
at them as here take hi know that you
love them let them know that there's tea
and I guarantee you like this perception
you have a black people probably teams
to all mine on black allies when you get
in those positions of power break down
this systematic way
[Applause]
and everybody please record this I have
a message for my preschool teacher he
was pretty racist towards me I was one
of the only black kids at my preschool
and he used to call me and randomly into
his office and he made me stand in the
corner by myself for hours I'm talking
hours by myself but guess what I'm still
here standing today every single
situation it was always blamed on me and
my brother because we were the only
black kids in our neighborhood so we
were always
[Music]
[Applause]
over and over again that good will win
please keep going
do not give up when you think it is over
it is knocked I'll basically want people
to know that it's not just from being
shot in the street because you're black
and brown it goes further than that okay
we've been dealing with this for too
long for nothing to change okay it's
hard for my people to get jobs over
other folks it's hard for us to get
wrong and I'm talking about school loans
house look like other way across the
board okay I want people to wake up wake
up and realize that it takes everybody
being together it's taking not just us
trying to stand up but it take the white
folk it takes Italian you take the age
and you take everybody that's in this
melting pot everybody to come together
and make this thing good I mean I got I
got a million a million and one times
where I've been treated funny just
because of who I am but I'm a military
veteran I'm a college graduate and you
know I'm nonviolent and I love people
and I'm just trying to really get a
better message so that way we can
elevate the humankind to the next level
instead of just you know running around
laying wrecks like we've been doing I
mean I don't get it they murder us and
they're telling us to be quiet
about them killing us comes to a point
in time where you have to stop caring
about skin color and start caring about
the war that we are in I know a lot of
people don't want to think that it's a
war but look around you look at the rice
that's happening across the country now
it is becoming a war and yes you're
gonna have to fight for your freedom
we're not special like any other
countries that you see that are tired of
their governments what do they do they
turn around and they fight they fight
for a [ __ ] lives I think Americans
black white Hispanic whatever am i
starting to see that there's no other
choice coming but to fight for your
lives we being peaceful out here and in
a couple hours they're gonna send the
beanbags they're gonna send it to your
guests and they're gonna shoot us for
being peaceful so you don't see how that
is ridiculous then you sleep and I mean
keep sleeping until everybody do the
overall message that I want to send is
stop killing us
just stop that's all I want to say is
just [ __ ] stop I rather die by the
coronavirus and Diana hazard police I'm
black i matter and i'm trans not feared
for my life every day but I'm out here
and I'm here with you guys black lives
matter all lives matter the trans live
matters as well we're not trying to
write the writing is just like the
process of what we're getting through or
going through the writing happened like
I said we're not here to ride we're not
here to break stuff but people are so
angry and like this has been going on
for years and this just happened you
know I want people to know that being
oppressed for 400 years does something
to people no matter who you are and the
fact that people are just focusing on
the buildings being destroyed and said
the black lives that have been lost it's
just kind of sickening because like you
can't bring back a life that you can
rebuild a building and people America
needs to wake up and see this is not for
anything
black people are trying to get a message
off for people to be heard because
people protesting we've been doing that
for years and they haven't heard us but
now they're hearing us because we're
making some noise
people ask me like what do you think
needs to change why does this keep on
happening and I think I know it keeps
having me because when you look at
anything person animal as lesser than
you it's easy to treat them as such
so I'm mixed I'm half black half white
one time I was in Columbus Ohio it was
me and my brother my cousin was black I
just so happened to have like the hoodie
on that day and we were walking in the
mall and as we were walking some didn't
know they were pleased at the time say
hey get against the wall I'm like no why
would I get against the wall trying to
walk around them they threw me to the
ground
my cousin jumped in they beat him up
pretty bad I didn't know how that
affected me as a child because I was 13
but as I get older and seeing these
things keep all happen over and over
again that made me realize and meet
someone who's not dark-skinned I can
only imagine if I was in a dark skinned
black person how they have to navigate
through this world and get profiled I
think it's just really important for us
to educate ourselves on things that
aren't so surface ask the hard questions
of why things are the way
I'm out here for black lives matter and
trans life Navi and it's really
important to me because I'm also a part
of the LGBTQ community and we all have
been getting hurt by a lot of the police
brutality that's been going on I just
really can't even believe the fact that
just a week ago or a couple of weeks ago
you had people protesting at the
Florentine wearing a mask because I
wanted a haircut with full armed rifles
guns with loaded ammunition but we're
out here protesting peacefully what
people want to gas us they make it
violent and all that extra stuff that's
just not needed one of the main reasons
why I'm out here is for my brother my
brother doesn't get the same privileges
me I'm black and I'm a female
my brother is black and he's a male like
he faces stereotyping in all of us
specially cuz he has tattoos so his life
has ten times were harder than me
he gets profound when he leaves the
house I'm not sure if he's coming home
to us and in one piece we never know so
that's why I'm out here we are tired we
are exhausted that we even have to
protest during a global pandemic
we just want peace and we just want
justice that's all we want and that's
all we've ever wanted there are people
who are taking these protests as chances
to live out their riot fantasies but
this is what we're about we're about
peace and we just want justice for all
everyone who dies and mercilessly we
just want to let you guys know that
silence speaks volumes
[Music]
fine
you